realiza algunas transformaciones para
intentar hacer que el triángulo móvil
coincida con el triángulo r de que es
este que tenemos aquí efe de los dos
polígonos son congruentes bueno ese es
el polígono que nos preguntan si es
congruente con este otro y nos dan estas
herramientas que es trasladar rotar y
reflejar lo primero que quiero hacer es
trasladarlo para acercarlo a la figura
que me interesa le doy trasladar tomo un
punto y lo nuevo hacia mi figura incluso
voy a hacer que estos dos puntos
coincidan bueno aquí vemos que podrían
ser congruentes pero para asegurarme de
esto primero tengo que hacer como el
reflejo de un espejo de este triángulo
azul de manera que este lado más largo
quede ahora del lado izquierdo reflejar
ponemos nuestro eje para reflejar aquí
en donde queremos que haya el reflejo le
damos clic aquí está muy bien bueno pues
pareciera que si van a ser congruentes
pero no falta de nuevo reflejarlo pero
ahora de manera que este lado largo
coincida con este lado este segmento r
vamos de nuevo a reflejar pero ahora
vamos a reflejarlo de manera horizontal
vamos a mover nuestro eje aquí lo
reflejamos y si queda exactamente el
triángulo azul encima de nuestro
triángulo r d por lo tanto si son
congruentes comprobamos respuesta es en
efecto así es